people who are living far below their
means enjoy a freedom that people busy
upgrading their Lifestyles just can't
fathom and I think that's very important
like just to not upgrade your lifestyle
all the time to maintain your freedom
and it just gives you a freedom of
operation once you make a little bit of
money you still want to be living like
your old self so that just the worry
goes away so don't run out to upgrade
that house and lifestyle and all that
stuff let's say you're getting paid
$1,000 an hour the problem is that when
you go into a work lifestyle like that
you don't just suddenly go from making
$20 an hour to making $1,000 an hour
that's a progression over a long career
and as that happens one subtle problem
is that you upgrade your lifestyle as
you make more and more money and that
upgrading of the lifestyle UPS what you
consider to be wealth and you stay in
this wage slave trap so I forget who
said it maybe it was Nasim tal but he
said you know the most dangerous things
are heroin and a monthly salary right
because they're highly
addictive here's the greatest news
physical Talent maybe that ever lived
and what was his life like well he was
bitterly unhappy and he died young
that's the life of
Mozart what the hell did Mozart do to
screw it up to make himself well he did
two things that are guaranteed to create
a lot of misery he overspent his income
scrupulously that's number one that is
really stupid then the other thing was
he was full of jealousies and
resentments if you'll spend overspend
your come and be full of jealousy and
resentments you can have a lousy unhappy
life and die young all you got to do is
learn from
Mozart there's a guy called Mr Money
Mustache so Mr money mustach was a
software engineer okay so now he has a
Blog and he's got you know big following
and whatever but when he was a software
engineer and he graduated at 22 he knew
that the gods were not so benevolent to
land him at Snowflake and then he just
rides that c tail into becoming a
billionaire he knew that that was not
what was going to happen to him so he
figured out he said he assumed that when
he graduated he would get an generic
programming job somewhere and playing a
generic salary with a generic basic
bonus living a very generic life and his
goal was that when he turned 30 that he
would be financially
independent and he would no longer be
working that was his goal when he
graduated so he said I've got 8 years
and I'm not going to be making high
incomes and I don't need a great amount
of you know comfort and such I'm so for
example Mr Money Mustache would not be
caught dead in a
Starbucks okay I mean $4 for a latte
that's not happening for him I mean he
would just you know he would choke if
that ever for him it's like more like
five or 10 cents Max for beverages in a
day okay if you go to his his blog you
will understand what frugality means
okay like he lives on like 8,000 or
$10,000 a year a new car not in three
generations would he ever buy a new car
and so like now he's in the woods of
Colorado somewhere so he retired at 30
he made a lot of money he retired
because he had no expenses and he's a
carpenter on the side so he built
himself his own Wood Shack in somewhere
in the middle of nowhere in Colorado and
lo and behold in his 20s he won he he
met Mrs Money Mustache okay Mrs Money
Mustache is even more dedicated than him
she's even more frugal than he is so
it's very important that if you're going
to be Mr money mustach that you find Mrs
Money Mustache okay so now the two of
them completely financially independent
quit their jobs he bikes everywhere for
everything and I think his annual
consumption of gas is like maybe 15
Gallons a year okay like one tank a
year when I was young one of my
principles was I I knew I had to make
money it was my overwhelming desire and
uh one of the things I did was I said
okay I'm never going to be worth more
than what I think I'm worth okay no
one's going to pay me more than what I
think I'm worth so what am I worth so I
I picked an hourly rate for myself that
I was worth and I said I'm never going
to squander my time for less than this
so if originally it was 500 bucks an
hour then I upgrade to 5,000 bucks an
hour and you know it's ludicrous but
pick an aspirational hourly rate
aspirational it has to be a little
ludicrous and then what I would do is if
if I have to return something I'm
standing in line to return something and
it's below my hourly rate I'll throw it
away if if I have to if I or give it
away if I have to do some task and I can
hire somebody to do it for less than my
hourly rate I would hire them and so I
just became extremely jealous of my time
which doesn't mean you can't have fun
rest Leisure spending time with your
friends and family that's all great
don't count that but if you're doing
anything you don't want to do which is
the definition of work it's a set of
things that you have to do that you
don't want to do if you're working it
better be for your hourly rate otherwise
don't do the work the tweet that we
skipped was there are no getrich quick
schemes that's just someone else getting
rich off you this goes back to the world
being an efficient place if there's an
easy way to get rich it's already been
exploited and there are a lot of people
who will sell you ideas and schemes on
how to make money but they're just
always selling you some $79.95 course or
some audio book or some seminar which is
fine everyone needs to eat people need
to make a living they might actually
have really good tips if they're giving
you actionable high quality advice that
acknowledges that it's a difficult
journey and will take a lot of time then
I think that's realistic but if they're
selling you some get-rich quick scheme
whether it's crypto or whether it's an
online business or seminar they're just
making money off you that's their
get-rich quick scheme it's not going to
necessarily work for you one of the
things about this whole tweet storm and
podcast is that we don't have ads on
here we don't charge for anything we
don't sell anything not because I don't
want to make more money it's always nice
to make more money we're doing work here
but because it would completely destroy
the credibility of the Enterprise if I'm
saying hey I know how to get rich and
I'm going to sell that to you it ruins
it when I was young and I was kind of
studying up on the topic one of my
favorite books on the topic was actually
called how to get rich by Felix Dennis
the founder of Max and magazine
billionaire who passed away and he had a
lot of crazy stuff in there but he had
some really good insights too but
whenever I read something by him or by
the GoDaddy founder Bob Parsons or say
Andrew Carnegie you read stuff by people
who are already very wealthy and they've
clearly made their wealth in other
fields not by selling the how to get
rich line they have credibility you just
trust them and they're not trying to
make money off of you they are obviously
trying to win some status and some ego
right you always have to have a
motivation for doing something but at
least that is a cleaner reason why
they're probably not lying they're
probably not fooling you they're not
snowing you if anyone is giving advice
on how to get rich and they're also
making money off of it they should have
made their money elsewhere like you
don't want to learn how to be fit from a
fat person you don't want to learn how
to be happy from a depressed person so
you don't want to learn how to be rich
from a poor person but you also don't
want to learn how to be rich from
somebody who makes their money by
telling people how to be rich it's
suspect anytime you see somebody who's
actually gotten Rich following some
guru's advice on getting rich just
remember that in any random process if
you run it long enough and if enough
people participate in it you will always
get every single possible outcome with
probability one there's a lot of random
error in there and then also this is why
you have to absolutely in completely
ignore business journalists and
Economist academics when they talk about
private companies I won't even name
names but like when a famous economist
rails on bitcoin or when a business
journalist attacks the latest company
that's iping it's complete nonsense
those people have never built anything
they professional critics they don't
know anything about making money all
they know is how to criticize and get
page views and you literally becoming
Dumber by reading them you are burning
neurons I'll leave you with a quote from
Nim taleb that I liked where he said if
you want to be a philosopher king first
become a king and then become a
philosopher not first become a
philosopher and then become a king let's
talk about compound interest compound
interest is basically the idea that
let's say if you're earning 10% a year
the first year you make 10% and you end
up with let's say you had a dollar you
invested you end up with a$1 10 but the
next year you end up with a121 and the
next year you end up with a dollar 32 or
3 3 so it keeps adding on itself in such
a way that if you're compounding at 30%
a year for 30 years you don't just end
up with you know 10 or 20 times your
money you end up with thousands of times
your money so compound interest is a
very powerful concept Einstein used to
say compounding is the eight1 of the
world and there are three variables you
need to get fluency in compounding and
you know we're not going to go there too
much in this class but there are three
variables that control compounding you
know your starting
Capital uh or the capital you're
contributing every every every year the
length of the
runway and your average analyze rate of
return and so if you think of those
three variables if the runway is really
long even with very small amounts of
capital and even with not such a high
rate of return you will end up with
spectacular sums so the most important
thing for all of you is start early so
if you look at someone like Warren
Buffett so far his Runway is 70 years
old he started in at the age of 20 with
10,000 and now he's 90 and he's been
compounding for 70 years if you look at
the 40-year Old Warren Buffett so
40-year-old Warren Buffett
19170 net worth less than 30 million his
net worth when he was 40 was less than I
think 13 3,000 of his Network today if
he hadn't G start started giving the
money away so this is the thing one of
the things about compounding is that
because it's geometric humans aren't
used to thinking geometrically you have
to become fluent in thinking
geometrically in your head now let me
leave you with two little Reflections
about this topic on the habit of
upgrading your lifestyle as you make
more money I really like Navada rikan's
tweet where he said survival replication
put us on the work threat Mill honic
adaptation keeps us there the trick is
knowing when to jump off and play
instead and on the topic of investing or
buying into a get rich quick scheme or
any other sorts of bad Investments Paul
Graham the founder of why combinator
wrote a very insightful essay titled how
to lose time and money in this essay he
shows that the most common way to lose a
lot of money is not overspending but
making bad Investments and this makes
sense because you can feel the
self-indulgence of over spending and
it's hard to spend it all at once
whereas in the case of a bad investment
you don't feel any
self-indulgence in fact you feel
productive and you can lose all the
money in one single moment so as you
make more and more money it becomes
increasingly important that you make
Sound Investment decisions as this is my
last video for 2023 I thought it would
be a cool idea to make a recap of my
four favorite tools this year for
Learning and productivity the first one
is notion which I use for taking notes
and managing projects the second one is
Obsidian which I use for making mind
maps of my nodes the third one is short
form an app with super high quality
study guides from hundreds of
non-fiction books which has helped me to
discover new ideas and learn much faster
and the last one is readwise which
consolidates in one place all my
highlights from ebooks and short form
and with its reader app I can even watch
YouTube videos and make highlights
directly on the transcript and I love
this because it's a way for me to build
my own personal library with all the
ideas that have resonated with me I also
have a partnership with shortone and
readwise so if you want to check them
out you can use my links down in the
description to get a way better deal
than
usual